[Music]
how good are you at learning languages
solving puzzles thinking logically and
putting pieces together well this summer
there's a competition where you can find
out and know it has nothing to do with
the World Cup mostly
[Music]
every once in a while I talked myself
into learning a new language before I
know it I'm checking out some course
from the library that has me solving
problems like this what do you mean
Kyle say of what your now feelings a
blank what is it what do you say
um what your exit oh good job but when
you get linguists and mathematicians
together problems look a little
different they're more like this
the sentence is on the left are in Zulu
the translations are somewhere on the
right can you match them before your
eyes glaze over and start rolling back
into your skull let me tell you that
everything you need to solve that
problem is right there in front of your
face that's the idea behind the
International linguistics Olympiad
coming up this July where this would be
one of the easy problems from Vasc to
barcodes bizarre notations to unfamiliar
accounting systems all kinds of problems
are up for grabs and really no expertise
is ever required other than your own
smarts Oh leave a comment to let me know
how you guys do in the meantime I'm off
to put some hard work into my regular
programming for all you thoughtful folks
who stick around and hit the subscribe
button stay happy keep those neurons
firing in thanks for learning with me
[Music]
you